ES6 has brought classes to the
language. Now, this is not a new
way to do object-oriented
inheritance. It's the exact same
prototypal inheritance that
we've always had in the browser.
It's just a new way to actually
write them. What I wanted to
do in this video is do a quick
review of how prototypal
inheritance actually works
because I understand not
everyone has a good grasp on
that. If you are totally
comfortable with prototypal
inheritance, skip this video and
I'll see you in the next one. If
not, stick around. What I
want to do here is let's make a
dog function that will create
puppies or create many dogs. I'm
going to say function Dog, and I
put a capital D on that because
this is what's called a
constructor function. That's
going to take the dog's name and
the breed of the dog. From that,
we say this.name() is equal to
whatever the person passes in
and this.breed() is whatever the
breed they pass in. I should
be able to say const snickers =
new Dog(). We're going to use
this dog here to create a puppy,
which is "Snickers." I'm going
to say the dog's name is
Snickers, and the breed is a
King Charles. Give that a save,
refresh. We have Snickers here,
which is a dog -- you can tell --
and the properties on it, breed
and name of Snickers. Now,
what is prototypal inheritance?
Prototypal inheritance is when
you put a method on the
original constructor, here, it
will be inherited by the rest of
them. Let's just talk about
what is existing. If I create a
new array, const names = Wes and
Kate. I just created a brand new
array, but now names.join() is a
method; name.pop() is a method.
We have all these methods on top
of names. Where did they come
from? Well, we have the MAMA
array, which is capital A, Array.
If you were to look inside of a
capital A, Array, you'll know
that that Array has many, many
prototype methods. What that
means is that when you create an
array or when you create a dog
from the MAMA array or from the
MAMA dog, every single instance
of that inherits those methods.
We're going to take a look at
how they don't just take their
own, they actually share the
same one. Let's add a prototype
method here. We'll say dog.
prototype.bark() =, and that is
a function itself, and we'll
just say console.log("Bark, bark.
My name is..."), and we'll put
this .name inside of there.
Why? Because we want to
reference the name of the actual
dog. I should be able to say
snickers.bark(). It says, "Bark,
bark. My name is Snickers."
Makes sense. If I were to
make a second dog here, and
we'll call that dog "Sunny." I
can say snickers.bark() and
sunny.bark(). "Bark, bark. My
name is Sunny." You see how this
one method that it declared on
the MAMA, the prototype here, is
now inherited by every instance
of dog. What's really cool
about that is I could then
change it after the fact. Watch
this. I can overwrite it. I
could say something like console.
log("Bark, bark"), and
maybe add some emojis in there,
Canadian dogs. And, "My name is..."
whatever and, "I'm a..." this
dog breed. Now, when I run
snickers.bark()...Even after
I've created Snickers and Sunny,
should it still do this?
Absolutely. What if I added a
second method onto it after the
fact? Dog.prototype.cuddle() =
function console.log("I love you
owner."). Even though, after
they were created, because I
modified the dog, I should be
able to say snickers.cuddle().
The way you can tell is if you
just type Snickers, you open it
up and you don't see bark or
name here. That's because these
things are specific to the
instance. The name and the breed
are associated with Snickers or
Sunny. But bark and cuddle,
those are on the prototype,
which means that they're not
part of the actual object,
snickers, itself. But if you
open that sucker up, you'll see
bark and cuddle are right inside
of there. They are inherited
from the parent. So dog
Sunny, you see
that Sunny also has access to
both of those. With that in
mind, let's learn about how we
can also do this sort of thing
when we write classes.